-And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"There Should Be a Law"
responses from you guys.
This first one is from
@Suzatthelibrary.
She says, "There should be a law
that if you play anything
on your phone out loud
on a public bus,
the bus must immediately sto
so other passengers
can throw you out the window."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes. Yeah.
This one is from
@Annabananagrace.
She says, "There should be a law
that you shouldn't tell someon
they look tired unless they're
literally asleep." Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, I agree with that.
-"Hey you look tired."
-"How you doing, Jimmy.
You look really tired."
-"You look real tired."
-Thanks.
-Thank you?
[ Light laughter ]
-"You look like
you're really sick."
-Yeah.
"Something wrong with you?
-"You'd tell me if you had a
stroke, right?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Somebody punch you
in the face?"
[ Light laughter ]
-This one is from @Miketbarrett.
He says, "There should be a la
that if people get to
swim with the dolphins,
then dolphins get to
walk with people, too.
It's only fair."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one is from
@immaddiemcneal.
-Oh, Maddie McNeal.
-I feel like I'm being
catfished.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-She says, "There should be
law that New York sidewalk
must have a tourist lane
and a New Yorker lane." Yeah
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's --
-Come on.
-That's what I'm talking about
I like that.
That's good stuff.
-This is a road people.
Move to one side if you're going
to look at a map.
-This one is from @realjordanb
They say,
there should be a law
that every Donald Trump
newspaper headline starts with
'Florida man.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Florida man
swallows tax returns."
This one is from
@Joeydestefano5.
He says, "There should be
a law against using sirens
in radio ads.
Am I getting pulled over
or can I save up to 15%
on my insurance for my RV?
Make up your mind!"
-Wee-oo. Wee-Oo. Oh, no.
Pull over now.
There's a great deal over at -
[ Light laughter ]
You in the blue Honda.
-This one is from @bgigglings.
She says, "There should be a law
that if you're still
paying student loans,
you can still qualify
for student discounts." Hey!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's actually a great idea
I agree with that.
[ Applause ]
This last one is from
@joannemj1.
She says, "There should be a law
that the final
piece of the puzzle
has to be placed by
the person who worked hardest on
it. You just got here, Paul.
Don't even think about swoopin
in on this at the last minute.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Paul!
There you have it, those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
[ Cheers and applause ]